eight starts this year it will be zach's
fourth
since coming off the engine list and his
first we're told with no limits and no
pitch cap
that's really good to hear for zach
allen i'm sure he's excited to go out
there and just compete
not worry about limiting his pitches or
anything like that although we'd like to
see him keep the pitch count down
two walks in the inning for gallon puts
him into trouble here with
alex dickerson coming to the plate the
one-two pitch from gallon to dickerson
and that's a swing and a miss struck him
out
chasm with a fastball off the plate
dickerson chased it and that's sound
number two first strikeout for gallup
grounded
back toward the middle escobar fields
and he will throw him out at first
so galin pitches around a couple of
walks in the first inning
by retiring dickerson and strike three
and crawford on an easy ground to the
second
take a look at alex wood what he has
done in 13 starts six and three with a
three nine one era look at the
strikeouts 73 and 71 in the third
there's a ball on the fifth the changeup
popped up towards short
over from third is flores and he makes
the catch
wood winds and throws change up grounded
softly to short right to crawford the
throw to first
and the inning is over and the side in
order for alex wood and after one no
sport
one strike offering swing and a line
drive base hit to left field
just to the left and above cabrera the
third baseman and that's the giants
first hit of the game
flores over the second and holding and
so tyro estrada
comes up it's the eighth hitter of the
game it's the fourth three-two count
already for zach gallon three-two that
one's lined into right field and tyro
estrada's got himself a hit
wilmer's getting the stop sign the throw
wasn't even coming home so now the bases
are loaded with the pitcher coming up
here's the 2-2 pitch strike three call
and wood
strikes out for the 17th time and now
lamont wade the leadoff hitter will step
in he walked to start the ball game
and wade drives one to center field on a
line
and heath is gonna make the catch wilmer
is gonna tag here comes that throw and
it hits the mound
flores scores and the giants have a
one-nothing lead
so the giants have one they want more
here comes jastremski
the 1-1 pitch the stremski swings to
change up ground ball
into right field base hit it went right
through the hole
nobody had a chance to get it and it is
two-nothing giants
the 1-2 pitch with two on and two out
his strike three call and posey knew it
he dotted him with a fast ball giants
get a couple
they'll leave a couple
one-two pitch and a swinging strike
three the slider running down and in
for a strikeout for alex woods
grind and a great catch by lamont wade
a headlong dive to his right to
intercept that one
and rob cabrera of a base head what a
heck of a catch that was
3-2 is strike three caught on the inside
corner
wood gets his second strikeout of the
ending second of the ball game
and for the second straight in and he
puts the diamondbacks away one two three
alex dickerson lead it off here is
dickerson he swings to the curb and he
hits a high drive
deep to right field and adios
pelota dickerson
jumping on that first pitch curveball
and hitting it out
seventh home run of the year for
dickerson he's behind o2
they go in with the fastball and he
lines it to left field for a two-strike
hit
nice hitting by granite crawford
a really good block that time by steven
vote brandon crawford is a really
alan down out there on the mound if he
just stumbled and lost his balance or
if he's waiting for the trainer to come
out this is by design
something went wrong right there he will
limp off the field here in the third
here it is and a ground ball to short
ahmed's got it he'll flip to second
that's to escobar
that'll retire crawford running down
there steven vote the one-time giant
and the left-hand battery in there
against the lefty alex wood
now the wind up 2-2 pitch swinging in
the missy struck him out with a high
changeup
strikeout number three for alex wood
five for 32.
now he swings and misses at a slider
down and away and out of the strike zone
strike three that's the fourth strikeout
for
wood including three in a row oh two
pitch
sliders struck him out swinging that's
five strikeouts
to looking for the first base hit today
that one goes right under the glove of
flores and into left
and he had to go to his left couldn't
get it and ahmed's got the diamondbacks
first hit of the night
yeah that's a thank you very much i'll
send you a christmas card bases are
going to be loaded here for astute
cabrera nobody out the pitch swinging a
shot to center base hit
it'll score a couple well escobar coming
to the plate the throws going to be
offline escobar scores sliding
and it's three to two on a two-run
single by as druva cabrera
t-backs have the bags loaded again one
out the banner is nick heath
and he struck him out again so he wanted
to throw that slider
seventh strikeout for alex wood 2-2
pitch
is hit on the ground to second fielded
there by estrada he's going to run to
the bag for the put out
and the inning at long last is over man
that was not easy runner in scoring
position for wilmer flores
2-2 pitch is ripped into left field
that's going to be a hit for flores
crawford comes to third and he'll be
sent home rojas
is going to throw into second base
wilmer flores knocks in a run
four to two giants that's a big one
fifth inning here's the pitch
estrada pulls this one and it's a fair
ball inside the bag at third down the
line
duggar will come in to score estrada
into second
and that makes it a 5-2 ball game
they've got their original three-run
lead back
two on two out in a 5-2 game giants lead
here it comes slider struck him out
swinging
beautiful pitch thrown by alex wood that
is out number three
the giants get through it woods probably
finished five innings
on the ground softly hit walker will
feed
mantiple didn't get there crawford was
able to beat it out
so it turns into an infield hit for
brandon crawford here's a push
ground ball down to third let's see if
they can turn two cabrera to escobar
then on the first double play
around the horn 5-4-3 nicely turned
cabrera to escobar to walker as they
double up floors in the inning
runner in scoring position back to the
top of the order lamont wade jr
to wade he swings he hits a high drive
into deep right field
way back there mario's pelota
way up into the seats in right field
more than halfway up
seven to two giants call to the bullpen
sherpy has done well with the giants
after they called them up from
aaa sacramento last month eduardo sends
one deep to right field
eduardo escobar 500 career rbis
his 18th of the year make it seven to
three 500
runs batted in dave and smith bidding
for one more that's deep to right center
field
it's gone haven't smith homers in
back-to-back games and it's 7-4
and the giants have the bases forward
he swings and hits a high drive deep
left field
welcome to the giants tyro estrada
and the giants have busted it wide open
now it
is 11-4.